As for the routes, I think here
these are largely logistical technical
issues, it will be worked out, it is already
being worked out, a difficult issue, for
example, our free supplies of
fertilizers that we are trying to arrange
for African countries also took a very
long time to agree on
coordination and so on, but they are all-
at least two such
deliveries have been made. As for
access to African countries, we have had
very serious contacts and
are continuing contacts with American
countries because it concerns the delivery of
Russian cargo, Russian grain,
including, of course, contacts are underway, efforts
are being made so that they do not feel
negative consequences African
countries in this sense They are here, I think that
now there is no need not to say because
they are really coming and what you called as a
promise from the Russian side that
these supplies
free of charge for Africans can be replaced with supplies
I think this will all be done and
fulfilled we propose  the format is probably
acceptable only after they
have been completed
We are ready to consider any options
We are ready to consider various
options for further continuing the
supply of grain to the world market
and grain and fertilizers
from Turkey We have very close
interactions traditional
interactions and we are also now
in contact with them and exchange  regarding what
to do in the current situation, you
know that there were at least
several tourist acts because
we
had a maritime humanitarian corridor
from Istanbul to relatively speaking to Odessa,
Chernomorsk South, along which it
was possible and necessary to safely pass here
and which were not subject to any
influence of force
but it was used as we know, they
talked about it for the organization,
it was Sevastopol,
that is, it’s like a lot of
factors came together here, Ukraine